Republican senator Ben Sasse of Nebraska
believes the United States is in the
midst of an unprecedented coming of age
crisis the former university president
has written a new book it's called the
vanishing American adult explores why he
thinks young people are in a state of
well perpetual adolescence senator good
morning good morning this is such a good
topic and we'll get to it in just a
second but let's just hit news a day off
the top the search for the new FBI
director some of your colleagues have
said it should be someone that does not
have a political background you agree
with that I think we have a crisis of
public trust right now and we need to
restore that the FBI is a really special
institution and the American people need
to know they can believe in it the FBI
director has a 10-year term for a reason
because it's supposed to be insulated
from politics I want to restore the rule
of law but also the institutional
conventions around that so there's more
trust and who created this trust vector
oh we should start at the beginning
right now we can go back to the 1960s
with the erosion of a lot of public
trust in America but it's been
accelerating obviously in recent years
Congress has a nine and a twelve percent
approval rating and we act like that's
normal and sustainable it's not all of
our institutions are in doubt and what's
going to happen in the future with more
disintermediated media is even more echo
chambers and silos even though we had
the power to do it would you include the
firing in the way it was handled of the
FBI director James Comey as creating
some sense of distrust of institutions
continued a collaborative study that
erosion yes the timing is is very
trouble yeah the timing bothers you I
there are obvious lots lots of
reasonable people can dispute whether or
not the FBI director who is a
fundamentally honorable man James Comey
is an honorable guy he's never going to
take a bribe in his life but he made
mistakes in the view of lots of people
in 2016 as he navigated the
unprecedented complexities of that
election cycle but once you get to a
place where there's an active
investigation the FBI director is not
supposed to be in a political chain of
command and that's the appearance of
this situation and it's timing
senator you talk about the vanishing
American adult I know it's not a public
policy but there's a lot of really
interesting stuff in here what do you
mean by that about the vanishing adult
too many of our kids are stuck in a sort
of state
of Perpetual adolescence it's not good
for them but this book is no old man get
off my lawn screaming it's about the
fact that we're not celebrating
scar-tissue with our kids they're with
20 year olds living at home with their
parents there's nothing wrong with an
intentionally multi-generational family
what's happening right now though is a
lot of drift for the first time in 130
years more 20-somethings and
30-somethings have moved back home then
established their own households part of
that is about declining economic
opportunity but a lot of it is about
initiative where it's hard to tell 10
and 15 and 20 and 25 year-olds apart
Neverland is a hell Peter Pan is a
dystopia we forget that we want our kids
to become adult you said Peter Pan is
not a good story about a man that
doesn't grow up but I left the story
that you open with the book talk about
kids that are not showing initiative
here you are a young president and
University something as simple as
decorating a Christmas tree left you
with a what the hell moment if you
thought houston we have a problem here
so I'm 37 I'm a new college president I
don't think of myself as that different
generationally than our college kids and
we have a big athletic arena and there's
a 20-foot Christmas tree and a bunch of
our really strong healthy well-rounded
vital vibrant students are supposed to
decorate it they decorated the bottom
eight feet and then they were leaving
thinking their job was done with the top
12 feet of the tree naked and one of the
vice presidents that the college
happened by and said what's going on
here and they said I don't know there
was no ladder and it would bother you
that nobody had the initiative to figure
this out yeah and what we should be
celebrating scar tissue and they needed
that experience to go and solve that
problem so just talk about civic
mis-education I mean the numbers in here
are startling about how few Americans
can name the three branches of
government yeah we have a crisis of not
understanding the First Amendment
freedom of speech press assembly
religion protests the right of redress
of grievances these are fundamental
these are the beating heart of the
American Civic experiment and we're not
teaching it to the next generation how
many your fellow senators and
congressmen and women understand some of
these basic things DC is not a very
urgent place I'm one of five people in
the US Senate I think five that's never
been a politician before I don't think
that city is supposed to be the center
of the world I think where people are
raising their kids and where they
worship and where they work is the
center of the world and DC has a kind of
fever that's often always about politics
and partisanship in today's screaming
and your problems addressing the urgent
policy and issues facing this country
whose addressing those issues yes I
think that's a good way of saying it
we're hollowing out local community and
mediating institutions right now and
we're politicizing our national
conversations so there are fewer and
fewer dinner tables and Rotary clubs and
civic communal events where we get
together and we discuss the shared
American narrative that's prior to
Republican versus Democrat policy
differences those matter but they're not
fundamental these are important
questions for you so you wrote this book
you also very critical of President
Trump would you consider running against
him in 2020 I've got the only two jobs I
want raising three little kids and
serving Nebraskans I commute every week
I think I'm the only commuting dad in
the US Senate I bring a kid with me
every week I get home on Friday
afternoon and my wife tells me who
annoyed her most this week and they
become my travel companion for the next
week so I'm content with my current
colleagues you can you can determine if
so is yeah you can do that because
they're homeschooled your kids are
homeschool we do hybrid schooling yeah
train them on the road right so we'll
see you maybe down the road thanks right
yeah because you didn't say no you know
they know for now he said senator very
good to see you the work is really a
great read a very important lesson for a
lot of a lot of us the vanishing
American adult is available tomorrow
wherever you like to buy your books